well it's estimated we make about thirty
five thousand decisions every day from
what to eat for breakfast to how to
spend money but with no so many options
it's often hard for some people to
choose as we found out I think you're
making like thousands of decisions to
like this island what to eat what time
to get up yeah
decision making is it pretty hard I own
my own business and so I just have to
make decisions all the time every
decision I've ever made in my entire
life that's been wrong if I make our own
decisions I don't know like I feel I'm
just like learning from it there's too
many options if I only had one choice it
would be easy well my brain wasn't up to
choosing between things so I got one of
everything you do me proud
I usually have like a top three yeah and
then at least I like those top three
sometimes you make great decisions and
you kind of tie yourself on the back and
other times you kind of fall on your
face I knew exactly what to do but in a
much more real sense I had no idea what
to do I'm impulsive so I'll make a
decision and then I think about it like
hour later and go why did I do that I
decided to do this area
researchers say there are two types of
decision-makers assessment
decision-makers do extensive research
but they often feel overwhelmed and
stressed when deciding then buyer's
remorse afterward locomotive
decision-makers choose quickly based on
available information they do not get
overwhelmed or stressed and are often
satisfied with their choice well
psychiatrist dr. su Varma is here with
some tips on how to get better at making
decisions good morning thank you thanks
so much for having so just lay it out
for us how do we become better
decision-makers because we are always
always having a problem with it
yes and you know we make thirty five
thousand decisions a day and 200 of
those are about food just by itself
right all of us are making food yes and
all of us are making decisions
throughout the day but and it depends on
person to person but also a moment to
moment so some of the variables are what
is our attention span in life in general
what is on our plate at this given
moment what's competing for our
attention what is our motivation how
much does this decision matter to us
what are the perceived consequences of
those decisions but also what is our
unique personality style which Michelle
you were alluding so a bunch of
decisions right there I've never but
you're a personality style so when you
were talking about the locomotive type
these are people who value action right
they are goal-oriented they want to get
on with a decision they want to move on
with their lives versus the people who
are assessment style or we call them
maximizers who are looking for accuracy
they value accuracy the truth their
perfection is one that's the Maximizer
or the assessment styles drive
themselves crazy now we all have a
little bit of each but we do have a
predominant style the maximizers are
never happy with their decision why
because they feel that they've left
something better on the job and when
you're talking about dating when you're
talking about picking a salad ice cream
right there's always been a movie on
Netflix I'll spend an hour and we we
don't reach a decision we play nothing
in the family it's called the Netflix
effect yeah can a person who is a
assessment decision-maker or a full
speed ahead decision maker can they be
married to one another does that work
absolutely yes
and usually it is and there's one person
who is kind of navigating the ship and
if you're somebody who trusts the other
first and say you know I'm gonna let you
make the decisions look there are
certain benefits of each of them and I
would say we are living in a society
where we're inundated with choice right
now the the the American Constitution is
based on freedom and we very much value
that of feeling empowered however we
don't realize that more choices actually
limit our freedom because we're spending
so much time for separating and
deliberating and we find that companies
actually when they limit the number of
choices people actually buy more product
you don't want to overwhelm people you
don't want to well you want all this
choice and then you become paralyzed but
yes so how do you make it easier for
yourself yes so that you don't become a
victim to decision fatigue which is a
big problem for choice overload you want
to narrow it down and this is especially
true for people who are maximizers but
in general even the people who are the
assessment Styles might get a little
freaked out if it's an important
decision so I would say limited to three
decisions look it's okay to have a wide
variety of things to choose from but
then limit it down to three and then I
would say ask three people not more than
that maximizers always look to get
people's opinions pick three people who
are relevant to the situation who have
experience then I would say give
yourself a deadline don't spend too much
time on it and once you make a decision
move on there's a great African proverb
that I love and it has to do with
finding a mate but it says before you
get married keep two eyes open once you
get married keep one eye closed
[Laughter]
dr. su Varma thanks so much for being
with us this morning